those pressures allow you to discover
this little world
forbidden world in many ways of violence
that
you could explore through sport you can
explore it
and uh it's more socially acceptable to
explore at this sport for sure and even
but even then there's like uh at times
it's socially unacceptable
so i beat sam schilt
i'm he cut my right eyebrow
i cut him and busted his nose and he's
bleeding all over me as i have an arm
bar on top i'm
getting you know it's raining blood just
quote some slayer
uh from a lacerated some shield bleeding
in his horror
creating my structures now i shall reign
in blood but uh
i win the fight
armbar nasty one i get on my feet
and the first thing i do is i wipe all
the blood
off onto my hands and i lick it and i do
my thing
and all the mma journalists freaked out
dana white's like man i don't know about
that you know
you know we don't want him doing
everybody had this huge problem
and then some folks would even contend
with oh you know what are you trying to
do like no no this isn't planned this
isn't i don't
think of these things this isn't this is
how i really feel this is who i really
am and you know it was even kind of
comical
after the fact you know and bj penn was
on the very card with me
watching him at some point in his career
all of a sudden win
fights and then and do this licking the
glove thing and everyone thinks it's the
coolest thing ever and i'm like hey
faces i did this in 2002
or 1 2001 and bj penn actually back then
was like dude you're a badass you're a
killer
you know where did that come from
because that seems like a deeply human
moment i could
say i could just be you know goofy about
it call it orgyastic
the title i would go back to mike tyson
yeah but tyson but uh no
no it isn't it's beyond that uh
is it pretty good that's pretty decent
orgasms in my life at this
point i'm 43. so but no none have ever
compared to that
like i said it is a feeling of highest
being to me
and ubermensch moment this is this is
where i feel like
the restrictions of general existence
in society are gone and i get to
fully live uh in a state that feels more
meaningful
of the most meaning you know i think of
it as life and death and
i it's just it is the way i'm built and
i don't have
i've never had any problem applying
violence like it doesn't
i i don't know where it comes from or
how you would define it or whatever if
you want to
stick me under in a psychologist's chair
but like i don't
there's a part of me that can just like
i know if i'm gonna apply i can apply
violence to any level
and be okay with it and it doesn't i
don't lose sleep
it doesn't bother me it's not a problem
it's it was me learning how to fully
understand
violence humans and the broader
perspective that allowed me to think
about things and like well
what am i what what do i really want to
accomplish with my actions in the world
just on a whole
you know not compartmentalizing uh my
sporting
career even when i get in the ring
i i don't have any mercy generally and
if i do it's because i make a
a really deliberate
attempt to be in a state where i can
have mercy
if i just go in there to fight with
everything i got
there is zero natural state there's
nothing there's nothing that will hold
me back other than
the referee and that's that you know i i
know i agreed
to to be allowed to do and not to do but
but within that
no and i expect it to be done to me but
in terms of values in terms of seeing
what
to me violence is uh is just yet another
canvas that humans can uh
paint beautifully on clearly i mean uh
we have venerated the violent
uh there are communists that venerate
the violent on their behalf there are
national socialists that venerate the
violent there
and then if you remove it from an
ideological perspective
we venerate the violent uh when they're
a hero
we venerate the violent in our religion
well i mean i guess some people venerate
the violence of of yahweh
and sodom and gomorrah right so or do we
say jehovah
i don't know
you